salut il est partout ils sèment la
terreur dans nos campagnes et sur
internet mais qui est-il vraiment
comment est ce qu'ils se manifestent
est ce qu'on doit en inquiéter je parle
bien sûr du point godwin et oui en
bresse était complètement marqué dans le
titre loïc générique le point de godwin
c'est un sujet passionnant et en
creusant pour les recherches j'ai vu que
ça aller assez loin dans le pourquoi le
comment avec des choses hyper étonnante
dont l'image qu'ont les indiens de la
seconde guerre mondiale j'en reparle
tout à l'heure mais je n'étais pas prêt
d'ailleurs j'étais pas tout seul à
creuser je les fais avec l'équipe de
curieusement magazine dont le numéro 6
vient d'arriver ou va arriver dans vos
boîtes aux lettres ce qui peut dire que
vous pouvez vous abonner dès aujourd'hui
pour le recevoir durant un an à partir
du 7 vous en reparle à la fin de la
vidéo
le point godwin ça vient d'une loi
empirique de mike godwin qui a dit en
1990 lui une discussion en ligne dure
plus la probabilité d'y trouver une
comparaison impliquant les nazis ou
adolf hitler s'approche de ce top pour
essayer de préserver la monétisation
cette vidéo je vais vous avez vu avec
les prochaines heures alors une loi
empirique d'abord c'est quoi merci
d'avoir posé la question dans les
commentaires c'est une loi ou une règle
ou une formule qui n'est pas née à la
suite de tests tout protocole à la pas
de vraie base théorie classique mais
elle est issue de l'expérience d'une ou
de plusieurs personnes
et bien sûr elle peut être ensuite
observé par d'autres il s'agit souvent
de théories qui doivent être ensuite
démontré dans le temps
le point godwin c'est donc le moment où
dans une discussion où un débat qui soit
dans la vraie vie en vrai ou sur
internet
l'une des personnes fait une référence à
un élément floral plus la discussion est
longue et plus ce moment est inévitable
goodwin qui à la base est un avocat
américain a créé une loi qui renforce
que le philosophe leo strauss avait
appelé en 1956 le reductio ad hitlerum
en gros c'est un procédé rhétorique
fallacieux qui sert à décrédibiliser les
arguments de quelqu'un en les associant
aux horreurs du passé
si ça c'est dégueulasse c'est ton
argument si je les mélange danse a fait
un truc dégueulasse
alors évidemment on voit ça bien plus
souvent sur internet que dans la vraie
vie déjà parce que sur internet on est
souvent anonymes ou quasiment parce
qu'on est derrière son écran en quoi
qu'il arrive
et ensuite parce que le temps internet a
tendance à tout accélérer une discussion
sur internet ça s'enflamme bien plus
vite que dans la vraie vie vous même
vous savez et je sais que vous avez déjà
vu ce cas de figure où ses parents un
insulte ou en comparaison directe avec
des marguerites
je vois des bouquets de fleurs arrivés
très vite sur mes comptes facebook ou
twitter mais aussi sur les forums et
parfois bien sûr dans les commentaires
de mes vidéos youtube mais c'est plus
rare
j'avoue le voir moins souvent voire
jamais sur mes comptes instat which tik
tok mais là la raison elle est assez
logique
les gens ne discute pas vraiment entre
eux sur twitter un petit peu plus mais
ils réagissent à ce qui se passe durant
le live et l'étoile vide
un petit plus avec un nombril au dessus
mais en gros sur ses trois derniers
réseaux les personnes laissent
majoritairement des commentaires
individuels sorte de réflexion
personnelle que se passe-t-il au moment
où la loi de godwin est constaté patrice
parce qu'il est temps d'arrêter de
discuter parce que une fois que les les
premières tulipes ont fleuri vous suivez
bien quand même le coup des fleurs
j'espère on n'arrive plus à revenir à
l'état de graines et c'est sans surprise
que c'est sur internet qu'on a commencé
à parler de point godwin
jusqu'à ce que des graphistes ou
aspirants graphiste en fabrique un
virtuel pour le mettre dans les
conversations sous forme d'image de même
d'ailleurs le point godwin ça signifie
pas forcément qu'on a atteint le point
où la comparaison au muguet a été faite
au contraire on distribue souvent à
titre préventif pour dire faites gaffe
les gars vous avez rajouté un point en
direction du fleuriste en gros ça peut
servir à rétablir un débat plus sain
pour éviter que ça parte en un pétale de
redonner
du coup plus on accumule de points tout
on arrive au moment où la loi de godwin
est démontrée mais on va pas se le
cacher c'est une forme de sophisme mais
j'ai envie de bien c'est un peu le
sophisme du pauvre d'esprit parce que
quitte à faire un sophisme autant le
faire avec un peu d'intelligence tu as
plutôt que la facilité de sortir dans
nos salles aux moustaches d'ailleurs au
final un sophisme seppois un sophisme
c'est une logique n'est pas légitime
on dit alors qu'elle est fallacieuse on
a l'impression que c'est un argument on
a l'impression c'est un peu logique on
peut même avoir l'illusion que c'est
évident du coup notre cerveau il nous
dit ok ça c'est vrai c'est validé on se
fait clairement avoir faut quand même
savoir que sa date puisque c'est apparu
en grèce antique
en gros les sophistes et c'était ce
qu'ils savaient convaincre d'une idée
par les mots quitte à être parfois
fallacieux ils ont obligé ainsi les
philosophes de l'époque a pensé à écrire
les bases de la logique pour qu'on fasse
un peu gaffe à pas sûrs embrouilles en
permanence dans le cas du point de
godwin
c'est une sorte de sophisme de
l'épouvantail on prend l'argument d'une
personne et on le manipule pour qu'ils
soient moins crédible alors en utilisant
un lien avec un bouquet de 39-45 donc
ils ont fait appel à des émotions
puissantes et soyons honnête personne ne
peut dire que cette période historique
est défendable du coup l'argument qui a
été manipulée pour y être associés il
est indéfendable de fait et c'est même
au sens propre un tabou culturel si on
essaie de trouver quelque chose positif
à l'équipe de fleuriste allemand
la réponse est oui sans surprise
internet fonctionne en majorité grâce
aux gratuits comme youtube par exemple
le gratuit fonctionne grâce à la
publicité comme youtube par exemple pour
attirer les annonceurs
il faut montrer aux marques que les
personnes utilisent le site
ça c'est vraiment schématique mais c'est
pour faire simple et l'une de ses
manières c'est de créer de l'engagement
le plus simple c'est des espaces
commentaire donc ce n'est pas un hasard
si maintenant on peut tout commenter les
articles de journaux les réseaux sociaux
et les services les produits n'importe
quoi en fait internet veut de
l'interaction est forcément les gens se
répondent ensuite dans les commentaires
et il commence alors à faire tourner le
compteur des points godwin
surtout s'il s'agit d'émettre une
opinion sur un fait sur une manière de
français sur une actu mais là vous me
direz oui me fabien 6 essence et partir
en sophisme pourquoi celui-là sur ce
thème là à chaque fois merci d'avoir
posé cette question aux commentaires et
laïque et tout de suite cette personne
et profitez-en aussi pour vous abonner à
la chaîne en cliquant là en psychologie
il existe un truc qui s'appelle la peur
du monde cette peur se serait l'un des
éléments qui nous permet justement
d'avoir un équilibre psychologique et le
plus jamais ça qui oblige positivement
au devoir de mémoire a fait passer le
chef des canaux me du statut d'
horribles dictateur sadique à monstres
ultime
et si on trouve même de manière
fallacieuse que vos arguments se
rapproche du mal extrême alors vous
pouvez plus le justifier et c'est pour
ça que la loi de godwin est inéluctable
et qu'on marque forcément des pointes
dans cette direction quand on débat sur
internet
de plus en plus longtemps
et bien aussi surprenant que ça puisse
être on a découvert avec l'équipe de
curieuses que l'on si on prend l'exemple
de l'inde
là bas il n'existe pas du tout et
j'insiste sur ce que j'ai à dire j'ai
pas dit il existe un tout petit peu il
existe pas du tout déjà parce que leur
rapport à l'affluence moustache c'est
pas du tout le même qu'en europe
vous pouvez même voir son visage sur des
pots de crème glacée sur des boutiques
sur des restaurants là vous vous dites
que les indiens ils ont dû avoir la main
lourde sur le curry rouge mais pas du
tout déjà la plupart d'entre eux ils
connaissent pas vraiment l'histoire de
l'europe pour eux notre monstre ultime
c'est juste un dictateur plutôt sévère
violent mais conquérant et aussi avec
une grande volonté dans leurs manuels
scolaires on rentre pas dans les détails
sordides de cette période de notre
histoire il connaît cette guerre-là me
connaissent pas comme on connaît avec
tous les éléments en plus de ça en inde
culturellement il aime bien s'approprier
l'image des personnes illustres
rajoutons à cela que la swatiska
qu'utilisaient les fleurs du mâle est
serré base chez eux un symbole religieux
hyper important de la religion hindoue
avant que le dé allemand détourné ça
bien sûr
en gros dans toute l'asie c'est un
symbole qui est bénéfique et on va même
comme ça jusqu'à tracé sur le crâne des
nouveaux initiés à la tradition bédat
j'ai pas réussi à trouver si l'inde avec
du coup son propre monstre ultime à eux
dans le sens où ils seraient irréfutable
mais si c'est le cas alors peut-être
dans ce cas qu'ils ont leur propre point
godwin indien
[Musique]
ne cherchez pas cette expression quelque
part je les ai inventées pour illustrer
quelque chose dont on parle pas beaucoup
peut-être pas assez le point godwin
s'est aujourd'hui assez connue pour
qu'on ne tombe pas vraiment dans le
panneau quand quelqu'un utilise ce
sophisme
en gros on arrête de discuter avec lui
parce que ans et qui pourra rien
entendre en termes d'argumentaire mais à
l'opposé c'est maintenant plus que rare
de voir un contradicteur logique
raisonnable pertinent expérimenté faire
la moindre allusion aux fleuristes de
l'extrême pourquoi parce qu'ils ont peur
de se prendre en face une accusation
fallacieuse évidemment de point godwin
ce qui rendrait à leur nul leur
précédente arguments on en arrive
du coup à une sorte de tapis même quand
l'utilisation de cet argument est
légitime et c'est vraiment un point peut
aborder et je trouvais ça important de
le mentionner ici je vais d'ailleurs
vous raconter une anecdote qui arrivé
lors de l'écriture du prochain numéro de
curieuses il ya un manque de la
rédaction au magazine il a posté les
informations un peu con glanées sur ce
sujet quand on creuse et ça il a partagé
sa sur son profil facebook à lui sa page
e prix d'ecouen 100 postes a été censuré
en moins de 180 secondes par la
modération automatique de facebook des
exemples comme ça il y en a plein qui
est dit sur internet et vous vous devez
reconnaître aussi sur youtube de vidéos
de vulgarisation qu'on était démodé
teasé ou supprimer simplement parce
qu'elle parlait de cette période de
l'histoire comme ça va être peut-être le
cas pour cette vidéo malgré les
précautions parce que c'est sa lettre on
est obligé d'avoir une sorte de
précaution maladive et sûrement
nécessaire tant que des humains ne
pourront pas vérifier au cas par cas les
propos liés à cette période dans la
publication vous le disais au début de
la vidéo le nouveau numéro de son
magazine mensuel que ryu sort en octobre
je vais vous montrer une partie du
sommaire pour info l'abonnement est à
partir d'environ 1 euros 65 par mois
frais de port inclus
c'est moins cher qu'un seul sur twitter
et c'est quand même plus intéressant
qu'un type i puisque vous recevez durant
un an 10 magazines chez vous de plus de
50 pages dans votre boîte aux lettres et
ou en version numérique cible avait
décidé dans la description vous avez un
lien qui va vous permettre de lire
quelques pages de curieuses mais aussi
d'avoir des articles gratuits d'anciens
numéros qu'on a mis en ligne vous allez
voir le site est très vivant on vient de
changer récemment au sommaire du
prochain curieuse on parle des
dérèglements temporelle de la
manipulation du cerveau par les couleurs
d'un philosophe volontairement oubliés
ou pan du fonctionnement de la prison
décision d'un dossier sur le point
godwin qui complète encore plus cette
vidéo et beaucoup d'autres choses
cinquante pages on a le temps d'écrire
des choses bref si vous voulez recevoir
vos 10 numéros par an aller faire un
tour sur curieux ce qu'on sait faire et
si vous avez des questions vous
trouverez sur le site la réponse dans
une très solide
faq et puis quoi qu'il arrive on est
hyper réactif je m'appelle toujours
fabien olicard n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner à cette chaîne c'est gratuit
activer la cloche pour pas rater les
prochaines vidéos ici je vous mets une
vidéo sur les variations vraiment
hallucinante du pierre feuille ciseaux
et ici une vidéo où justement j'ai dû
argumenter pour changer l'opinion d'un
médecin sur un plateau de télé bref
j'espère que le prochain numéro de
curieuses va vous plaire autant que les
précédents prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt
charpy